[Music]
Friday's justice recovery day because
Jay King is so intense swap our straight
talking about nonsense so tiring right
to what brain power hates a lot of study
it is exhausting I agree you know how
I'm never really a part of JT news all
that often but on the days that I am I'm
like wiped out by the time I'm headed
home from JK news just because the
conversations and the speed of the
conversations - like if you're not
trying to say anything you'll never get
to say anything no one ever leaves space
for you to actually say your piece
unless you kind of forced your way into
the conversation and everyone's you know
kind of amped up for the cameras a bit
so yeah it is very exhausting my
breakfast because I'm bored these cats
don't suffice you know you're really
cute I am I am why is the daddy's girl
and so is the mama's boy and it's crazy
that he always goes to her and you
always come to me like you know you know
our genders and you seek out that
father's love or the mother's love you
want breakfast no won't sleep okay is it
cool if I make myself breakfast yeah I
did a rewarding I'm gonna go extra fancy
today Oh what are you doing that has
these pork chops in the fridge I'm
thinking pork chop and eggs makes a left
waffles no he's like and in the morning
I'm making waffles oh yeah all right
breakfast time
[Music]
so for breakfast I think I'm going to
make some soft-boiled eggs some pork
chops and some toast now the catch is I
don't have a toaster so I'm gonna have
to make toast the non toaster way and in
order to make soft-boiled eggs you have
to have to have to time it because with
the cooking eggs it's a very precise
timing thing because eggs cooks so
easily even in like 30 seconds more the
texture and the run enos and the
softness of the yolk can changed to
being more of a hard-boiled egg I'm
gonna show you guys how to make a
soft-boiled egg real quick alright so
the first thing you're gonna want to do
is bring the water to a boil and then
reduce it down to a simmer take your
eggs and you'll lower it into the water
I'm like 2x they cover it and then you
set your timer for 6 minutes turn off
the heat and you want to cool it
[Music]
there's residual heat inside the a so
the eggs gonna actually keep cooking on
its own what we want to do is stop that
cooking process by running it in cold
water and then after that got two
soft-boiled eggs onto the pork chops
[Music]
all right this ladies and gentlemen
there's a soft-boiled egg that it's
gorgeous
perfect soft-boiled egg toast something
I like to do take some toast take your
egg this is the best right here
de beste is better than butter and jelly
for chairs all right so Casey had
breakfast I slept in a little longer and
now we're at the office we're here to
meet with Michael that's some business
stuff and I heard that they painted the
office so we're approaching the office
door right now
your expectation for it I heard it's
yellow some I'm picturing yeah exactly
uh wha no not personally the other one
over Thurman in Kill Bill yeah I know
but I didn't know Bruce Lee first I knew
first so that's the first reference that
comes to my mind when I think of black
and yellow another song this is
interesting it does give a lot of pop
wow they even painted the light didn't
want to tape that hood well in that room
is green now oh it is green oh it was
that one wall some color little over
mesh is your nuisance
oh it does oh sure on camera though it
doesn't look as bright as it doesn't
person you look so tanned in this
hallway really yeah it's like really
yellow
yeah I'm like why are you sending the
brick are you guys are you gonna wear
your bristly shoes - oh yeah should I
shut up Wow so now there's this samurai
dude right by my bed kind of creepy
they're having a meeting I've been at my
desk and what feels like forever because
we don't really have to come to the
office only whenever we have meetings
and stuff that's kind of rare
so my desk gets neglected a lot of the
times I never get to use this baby I
never never in my even when I'm here for
meetings and stuff I'm never in my
actual office I'm in Bart's office or
the conference room or everywhere else
but my own office you know
an entire room to yourself you know we
should do would you be down to have me
move into your office and then we can
clear up space so then the editors could
have this place for them to work it off
and just consolidate you and me together
in one room yeah and then plus it'll
make more sense because every time we
have lunch I always go to your office
anyway we might as well work together in
the same space yes I agree you don't
think it would get tired of me seeing me
at home all day and then seeing me in
your office I'm a carpool a lot too
another reason why I married you is
because I could stand you you don't get
on my nerves
I mean sometimes everyone does
eventually but I think for you it's like
much less oh I've been previous
experiences so that's weird man you're
next I put a rock on that thing oh
thanks well you annoy me too so that's
good yeah
[Music]
yours and yours and yours are all for
the same day yeah I don't like chocolate
all that much cake and I don't like this
ice cream flavor and I don't like any of
this so that means you're giving it to
me
I am oh really come up anyways we're
meeting yeah
[Music]
so we finished up our meeting we picked
up the boy every day all working on my
fork cuz we changed it to a ultimate
spaceship that's enough the spaceship
yeah yeah what was the name of it again
told to it spaceship what did you call
this a battlefield baby always switched
it's the ultimate spaceship of time at
the time I really don't know well I need
a gun right here and I walked in here
and I was like hey this was you stuff
going on would you do what is this
so this is a gun for the inside which
there's a control and then this is a
rocket that shoots out what you Reeve a
missile launcher yep
you made this yeah you're still creative
dude what'd you do this yeah yesterday
while I was at jakey news yep this is
awesome and you cut it yourself yeah
this is so cool oh I put some pieces of
shrapnel lion guard
hey hey I'll pay you billion dollars use
a soft cuddly guard I think a lot of
people a billion dollars chi-ching
chi-ching good you gotta take a shower
man he's starting to smell like a fish
out is that stinky smell yeah and you
just got home you're all sweaty
you smell like a boy now it's so weird
you any pie mind me don't you who's
taking a break I'm smother him and then
he leaves I guess mother hens oh no way
turn the camera League of like jealous
one sitting like the furthest the way
all like I would like to though is my
like a mama's boy so I always play with
though
and then finally theory she's like
poking through like a furniture or
something or around the wall and then
she's always like this I want to join
too
so this is where I Drive this is
autopilot so you press this over your
present and you stuck your thumb in here
that turn the whole thing off press for
autopilot what happened did you mess up
yeah I couldn't spell pilot right you
can see you like a little road where you
just fill it yeah but I couldn't spell
it right all right here is where I shoot
the gun I mean this is the rocket and
this is the engine so whenever I'm
driving this is like where stop flip
flips
okay what is is what what pieces are
these pieces wait so how come you did us
these long strips for these tiny little
so it could be like buttons from Star
Wars it's kind of complete oh so it's
just the buttons are in imagination it's
because I don't have my you're the
program my Star Wars the sound effects
or I mean sorry not sound effects it's
the sound of your engine yeah with the
program your relax is so easily with you
he never relaxes with me he's a mama's
boy no escape while you can so you're
telling him this get weak cuz you can't
escape because you said escape we trying
to cuddle with you silly what are you
guys doing everywhere wait this one yep
all right in three two one
[Music]
water all over me
[Music]